We were talking last time about evidence
of the use of different sources in the
biblical text.
And I mentioned Richard Seaman,
who was the first to argue that perhaps
Moses wasn't the author of the entire
Torah.
Uh,
in the mid 18th century fella named John
as through first notice the use of the
name Yaffe way in certain stories and
passages and the name Elohim and others.
And on this basis,
uh,
he came and others came to identify what
I've come to be known as the j and east,
uh, sources Jay being pronounced.
Yeah. In German, right as a y.
So we, a Yak way is spelled with a
j. So the j and the east sources.
Now as stroke actually happened to
maintain the idea of mosaic authorship.
He argued that Moses was drawing
from two separate long documents,
which he identified as j and d.
Um,
they use different names for God and he
was drawing on those in his composition
of the Torah.
But in the next century,
his work would be expanded by Germans
who identified other sources that made up
the pentitude, especially the
first five books of the Bible.
Especially in an 1878 we have the classic
statement of Biblical source theory,
uh,
published by Julius vel housing.
He wrote a work called the history of
Israel and he presented what is known as
the documentary hypothesis.
Now you've read a little bit about
this in your source readings,
but it's the hypothesis that
the historical or narrative
sections of the Bible,
genesis and and stretching on really
through second kings is comprised of four
identifiable source documents that have
been woven together in some way and he
argued that these documents date two
different periods and reflect very
different interests and concerns.
These four prior documents he says,
were woven together by somebody or
some group of somebodies to form the
narrative core of the Bible and Vel
Hausen argued that these sources therefore
do not tell us about the
times or situations they
purport to describe so much as
they tell us about the beliefs and
practices of Israelites in the period in
which they were composed.
This is going to be an important
claims is an important predicate of the
documentary hypothesis.
So although the sources claim to talk
about events from creation actually
forward a bell houses says no,
they really can only be used to tell us
about the beliefs and religion of Israel
from the 10th century, which is when
he thinks the oldest was written and,
and forward. Now his work created
a sensation. It undermined,
of course, traditional claims
about the authorship of God and,
and the work of Moses.
It's still disputed by
conservative groups. Um, and
Roman Catholic authorities.
Although Roman Catholic scholars,
I'm certainly teach it, um,
and adopted the four sources that
were identified. My vel Hausen are,
as I said,
the j source and the source,
but also p the priestly source and d,
which is primarily the book of
Deuteronomy. Now, as I said,
the first two sources are named because
of the names of God that they employ.
But it goes a little deeper than that.
According to Jay,
the knowledge of the proper or
personal name, if you will, of God.
He halfway begins with the
first human, with the Adem. Um,
so already in genesis four,
a damn seems to know this name
and refer to God by this name.
If we look at other sources such
as p and even e, uh, Yaffe ways,
name is not known to humankind until
he chooses to reveal it to Moses.
And this happens in the time
of the exodus. So in exodus
six versus two to three,
which is assigned by source critics to
the piece, or it's the priestly source,
God appears to Moses and he tells them,
tells Moses then that he is Yahweh.
He says, I appeared to Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob the Patriarchs
before you as El Shaddai,
but I did not make myself known
to them by my name. Yeah. Anyway,
so the piece where it has a different
sort of theology, if you will,
of God's name or the revelation of God's
name and the same sort of thing happens
in exodus three,
verses 13 to 16,
and that's assigned to the east source.
So once you've identified rough blocks
of material according to not just the
name of the DD,
but also there are assumptions about
when humankind knows the name of the DDT,
then you could analyze these blocks are
chunks of texts and begin to identify
certain characteristic features.
Um, their, their, their style,
the terminology they use
and source critics were able
to come up with a list of
what they believe were the main
characteristics of the various sources.
So the main characteristics
of the j source,
which begins with the
second creation story.
So the j source picks up in Genesis two
verse four, second half of verse four.
It is that it includes, it
uses a personal name. Yeah,
I'll wait for God from the
time of creation and that
will be in your bibles as
Lord. It describes God. I'm
very anthropomorphic Lee.
It's the j source that has god shut
the door of the ark after Noah.
It's the j source that has god
smelling the sacrifice after the flood,
the sacrifice that Noah offers.
It's in the j source that God eats
with Abraham and bargains with him.
It's in the j source that God meets with
Moses in this mysterious passage and
tries to kill him one night.
Um,
Jay has a very vivid and
concrete earthy style.
It uses the name Sinai,
Mount Sinai to refer
to the place where the,
where the Israelites with Moses
will conclude the covenant with God.
As for the date,
well source critics felt that a clue
to the dating of the j source could be
found in the passage in which God
promises a grant of national land to the
Israelites. The boundaries of the land
are given there as the river of Egypt,
the Nile,
and the Euphrates.
And it was argued by some that those
were basically the borders of the Kingdom
of Israel under David and Solomon.
What to think of 1000 as
your for David and your,
that's basically when the monarchy begins.
All right,
so the beginning of the 10th century,
the argument is that under David
and Solomon, the empire reached the,
that boundary.
And so clearly this is a writer from the
10th century who's seeking to justify,
um, Israel's possession of its
kingdom from the river of Egypt.
To the Euphrates and it's presenting that
kingdom as a fulfillment of a promise
of land that God made to Israel's
ancient ancestors. And for that reason,
source critics thought,
Aha,
Jay must date to about the 10th century
under the time of perhaps King Solomon.
It also seems to reflect the
interests of the south member.
We talked about the fact briefly that
at a certain point in Israel's history,
there's a division, uh, upon the death
of Solomon and the late 10th century,
the kingdom,
the kingdom divides into a northern
kingdom now called Israel and a southern
smaller kingdom called Judah.
And the southern interests seem
to be reflected in the j document.
So source critics decided this is a
Judean document from the 10th century.
The source,
which source critics say begins
around Genesis 15 is really the most
fragmentary.
It seems to have been used to supplement
the j source rather than to be used in,
in any hole, in, in a, in a larger forum.
So sometimes it seems very difficult to
isolate and there's a lot of debate over
this, but the east sources characteristics
are that it uses Elohim. Again,
it's a plural form of
the word God or gods.
But when it's used with a singular verb,
it refers to the god of Israel.
It has a much less
anthropomorphic view of God.
God is more remote.
There aren't the direct face to
face revelations in the east source.
Most communications from the divine
are indirect. There'll be, uh,
through messengers or dreams,
and there's also an emphasis
on profits and prophecy.
In the East source, Miriam Moses,
they're both, uh, referred to as profits.
In the East source,
the style is more abstract,
little less picturesque,
and the source uses a different name
for the mountain where the Covenant was
concluded. It uses the name
Horeb. All right, you'll see,
you will sometimes see as
you're reading the texts,
they refer to Horeb
instead of Mount Sinai.
Or you'll see the two names
used interchangeably. And it's,
it's been the theory of scholars that
that's because it comes from a different
source. The source seems to be
concerned primarily with, um,
the northern tribes.
Then therefore the northern kingdom.
And so source theorists decided that it
was most likely composed in the northern
kingdoms. About the ninth century.
And then according to this hypothesis,
theJ and e sources were combined primarily
Jay with he being used to supplement
it probably somewhere in the eighth
century, late 18th century. Um,
and that was the backbone of
the pentitude Tukul narrative.
It covers the early history of humankind,
Israel's early ancestors known
as the Patriarchs and matriarchs.
Their stories are told in genesis.
It contained the story of Moses and the
exodus from Egypt in the book of Exodus
and the stories of the wandering in the
wilderness that are found in the book of
numbers and the anonymous
scribe or editor who, uh,
combine these sources didn't care
to remove any redundant material or
contradictory material. Um,
as we've already seen. Now,
there are two other sources
according to classical source theory,
and these are d and p d,
which is the dude or anomic source is
essentially the book of Deuteronomy.
And the book of Deuteronomy
differs from the narrative sources.
This is a book of speeches on the book
purports to be three speeches delivered
by Moses as the Israelites are poised
on the east side of the Jordan River.
I'm not good with directions.
I had to stop and think the east side
of the Jordan River about to enter the
promise land. Um, but according
to this source theorists,
it clearly reflects the interests
of settled agrarian life.
It doesn't reflect the interest of
people who've been wandering around and
automatically it has laws that
deal with settled agrarian life.
The main characteristic of d,
however,
which assisted source theorists in
fixing it's date is the following.
Do you use the one source in the Bible
that clearly insists that one central
sanctuary only is acceptable to gateway?
God cannot be worshiped
at makeshift alters.
God cannot be worshipped through
sacrifices at some local sanctuary.
All sacrifices must be offered in the
one central sanctuary where he will cause
his name to dwell.
It doesn't actually ever say Jerusalem,
which is why Samaritans think that it's
out meant resume and that they have the
correct temple and they are authorized
to offer sacrifices. All right?
They got it wrong when they
thought it was Jerusalem.
Samaritans think that that's where
God caused his name to dwell.
So Jerusalem is not actually mentioned
in Deuteronomy. That's a later reading,
but the place where God will cause his
name to dwell and only there at the
temple there can there be sacrifices.
This is a very different perspective
from other biblical books.
So you're going to see in the,
in the stories of the Patriarchs that
they're wandering all around the land and
they're offering sacrifices. And there
are other books too where it's clear.
There are local shrines,
local sanctuaries,
local priests who are offering sacrifices
for people throughout the land.
But Deuteronomy insist
one central sanctuary,
all of the outlying altars and
sacred places must be destroyed. Now,
central centralization of the cult was a
key part of the religious reform of the
King of Judah in six 22. I've marked a
couple of dates on the timeline up here.
So seven 22 is the fall of
the northern kingdom. Six 22,
I reform my King Josiah in Judea.
We read about this in one of the
historical, um, narratives, um, where,
uh,
the temple's being refurbished.
A book has found that says one
central sanctuary King Josiah says,
what have we been doing?
Get rid of the outline alters
everything has to be centralized here.
So that reform, the Josiah's reform, um,
has caused many scholars to associate
Deuteronomy the centralizing book or
source,
um,
with the late seventh century
around this time in Judah.
The trouble is d seems to reflect
it out of northern traditions.
The interests of tribes who were in
the north on the northern kingdom was
destroyed. And seven 22. So
this is the theory source.
Critics conclude the DS and old source.
It was originally composed in the north
and the 18th century when the northern
kingdom fell,
when the Assyrians conquered and many
Israelites would have fled to the southern
kingdom, Deuteronomy or this, the
DEA source was brought to Jerusalem,
stored in the temple where a hundred
years later it was discovered and it's
centralization, was put
into force by King. Josiah
p is the priestly source and that is
found mostly in the books of Leviticus and
the non narrative portions of numbers.
Now,
the major characteristics of p the
priestly source are a great concern with
religious institutions,
with the sacrificial system,
with the Sabbath, with holidays,
with rituals like circumcision.
The Passover dietary restrictions,
the laws of cash route,
the system of ritual purity and impurity,
um,
and also holiness, ethical holiness
and cultic or ritual holiness.
P does have some narrative and
you've read some of it. Genesis one,
the first creation account is
attributed to pee. It's orderly,
it's systematized.
The God is extraordinarily abstract
because in the piece source,
another characteristic is that God is
transcendent and even perhaps remote much
more so than in j for example.
Um, generally in the piece source,
God is concealed and
revealed only in his covered.
This is a word that's often
translated as glory. Um,
but what it refers to actually
is a light filled cloud. Um,
God seems to be the burning fire
inside this light field cloud.
He travels before the
Israelites in that form,
leading them through the wilderness and
so on. That seems to be in the piece.
Source.
P is also interested in covenants,
in censuses, in genealogies,
all of those sections,
very often that link stories, um,
are attributed to the piece source.
And because p elements often serve that
kind of function as a bridge between
stories or very often piece sources
seem to introduce a story or conclude a
story. I'm the source. Critics
felt that priestly writers,
we're probably responsible for
the final editing of the Bible,
bringing together j and d and d and
adding their materials and finally editing
the work. Now, bell housing data,
the priestly source to a period,
the exit like period to the period after
the fall of the southern kingdom and
five 86 when the Babylonians have
taken many of the Judeans into exile in
Babylon.
So p j and the narrative parts,
the narrative parts of P J
and e are continuous parallel
accounts of the history
of the world, if you will, from creation
until the death of Moses. Source.
Critics believe that they have a
uniform style, uniform vocabulary,
uniform set of themes,
and a chronological framework.
So according to Vail Housing and I've
sort of scheme Matteis to chronologically
for you up here,
the priestly school drew together
all of this older material,
added some of its own editorial
material, bridges, introductions,
conclusions inserted the large priestly
documents of Leviticus and numbers and
so the Torah and they did this sitting
in exile in Babylon and so the Torah is
really the result of five centuries of
religious and literary activity and this
of course is a very,
very different portrait from traditional
claims about the authorship of the
Pentateuch by one man Moses in
approximately the 14th century BCE.
There are different terms that we use
to describe the modern critical study of
the Bible in the late 19th century as
I've just described it a one term is
literary criticism because it proceeds
by closely analyzing the literary
features of the text, the
terminology, the style, the motifs,
but because the goal of this literary
critical school was to identify specific
sources, isolate sources, we also
refer to it as source criticism.
You'll see those terms used
interchangeably in your literature today.
Literary criticism has a
slightly different connotation
from what it was in the
19th century. So people prefer
the term source criticism,
but you should know both
are used because however,
the purpose of identifying and isolating
these sources was not just to say,
look at that.
There are these different sources.
The purpose was to ascertain as far as
possible they're relative dates to one
another and to therefore enable the work
of historical reconstruction to proceed
primarily a reconstruction of the
history of the religion of Israel and the
historical situation of the
authors of the different sources.
And therefore literary criticism is
not only called source criticism,
it's also called historical criticism
because it's ultimate goal and purpose was
not just to isolate the sources
but to rearrange them all right.
According to relative dates as
far as they might be ascertained.
And then to chart changes
in Israel, uh, uh, religion.
Um, you have a very readable
introduction to some of this in,
in Norman hobbles a little work,
another excellent work which is
not on your syllabus. That is also,
I'm critical of vel and some of the biases
in his work is found in a little work
called who wrote the Bible,
um, by Richard Friedman,
which has a great cover cause it says
who wrote the Bible? Richard Friedman.
So always, I love that.
So to sum up the dock,
your documentary hypothesis is an effort.
It's an effort,
I hypothesis an effort to
explain the contradictions,
the doublets anachronisms and so on in
the Bible by means of hypothetical source
documents. So the theory posits
hypothetical sources, traditions,
and documents to explain the current
shape of the tour of the way we have it to
account for some of these phenomena
that we find as a next step.
The sources are assigned relative dates,
not absolute dates, relative dates.
And then they're analyzed to reveal the
different stages of Israel's religious
history and sole source criticism is also
known as historical criticism because
it's a tool for getting at the
history, not just that, the texts,
but ultimately history of Israelite
religion. That is how it has been used.
Now Ville House's work is
subtle and it's quite brilliant,
but it's certainly reflects,
um,
biases of 19th century German scholarship,
which believed strongly in the superiority
of Christianity or Judaism in his
writings about housing has some things
to say about Judaism that are none too
flattering.
He describes Judaism at the end of
the biblical period as a dead tree,
twisted and perverted.
He especially harbored
a distaste for things.
Cultic priests,
cult ritual in keeping with what
was going on in Germany at the time.
Um, and, and, and the
Protestant movement and so on.
And these sorts of biases
are very apparent in his
work and very apparent in his
dating of the sources and in his
description of the evolutionary stages of
Israel's religion.
So for example,
source critics before vel Hausen
all thought that p the priests,
the material with some of the
oldest material in the Bible,
that it was an early source, but
Bellsa they'll house and said, no,
it must be a late source because
priestly cultic ritual material,
that's clearly a degenerate,
uh, stage of religion, um,
that that shows a sort of guilt ridden.
Um,
behaviorism that's not
true spiritual religion.
So clearly that's the latest,
um,
stage of Israelite religion
when it had died, uh,
and was waiting to be reborn in new
form with the arrival of someone in the
first century. Uh, so clearly a,
his dating of p owes a great deal to um,
his,
his biases and religious ideology.
So he saw the priests.
The material is having to come
from the like age post five 86,
and this is one of our houses,
most controversial points that
still hotly debated today.
And we're going to be turned to this
debate when we actually take a look at
Leviticus and numbers.
Um, and when we, uh,
at that time we'll be able to see what's
at stake in the whole question of the
dating of the priestly material.
The historical critical method and the
documentary hypothesis in particular are
not inherently biased.
I want to make that point very strongly.
They are simply analytical tools,
right?
Look at the text and its features and
draw some conclusions based on what you're
finding. They are simply analytical
tools. They're not inherently biased.
They can be applied fairly to the text
and they're extraordinarily useful.
It's just that some of the earlier
practitioners of these methods, uh,
did have ideological axes to grind
and we need to be aware of that. Um,
the documentary hypothesis works fairly
well when you have on parallel accounts
and works a little bit less well when
the accounts are interwoven because
sometimes picking apart the sources can
become dry and mechanical sometimes to
the point of absurdity.
Um,
some of the people who have
carried this method to its extreme,
we'll go through and almost word
for word, this is Jay. This is he,
the next word is p.
Um,
it's quite remarkable how certain they
feel that they can break things down
almost on a word toward basis as if an
editor sat there with scissors and paste
and we're cutting out word for
word and putting them together.
It's sometimes can reach heights of
absurdity and it can really destroy the
power of a,
of a magnificent story.
Sometimes when you carve it up into
pieces that on their own don't really make
all that much sense.
It needs to be remembered that
the documentary hypothesis
is only a hypothesis,
an important one in a useful one and
I certainly have used it myself. Um,
but none of the sources posited by
critical scholars has been found
independently. We have no copy
of Jay, we have no copy of ea,
we have no copy of p by
itself or d by itself.
So these reconstructions are based on
guesses. Some of them are excellent,
excellent guests is very well supported
by evidence, but some of them are not.
Some of the criteria
invoked for separating.
The sources are truly arbitrary
and extraordinarily subjective. Um,
they are sometimes based on all sorts
of unfounded assumptions about the way
texts were composed in antiquity.
And the more that we learn about how
texts in antiquity were composed,
we realize that it's perhaps not unusual
for a text to use two different terms
for the same thing within one story since
we find texts in the 16th 17th century
BCE on one tablet using two sources,
two different terms for a story for two
different terms to which kind of the
same thing. So, um,
the criteria that are invoked
for separating sources
often ignore the literary
conventions of antiquity.
And the more that we learn about that,
the better able we are to understand
the way the biblical text was composed.
Repetition isn't always
a sign of dual sources.
It often serves a rhetorical function.
Variant terms aren't always
assign of dual sources.
They may have a literary
or aesthetic function.
So while most scholars today do accept
some version of bell houses theory,
yes, we feel the Bible is
composed of different sources.
We don't always have tremendous confidence
though in some of the finer details
and conclusions of his work and the work
of other scholars who followed after
him.
Some doubt the existence of e altogether
it is so fragmentary and so isolated.
Others defend the antiquity of
p we'll be coming back to that.
Others argue that everything's
posted Zelig everything's
after the fifth century.
It was written in the fourth,
third century and the Persian period,
none of it comes from an older period.
Scandinavian scholars,
they're not enthusiastic
about source criticism at all.
The whole Copenhagen School
of Bible Scholarship, uh,
prefers many of them prefer to see.
The Bible is basically an oral narrative
that just grew through creation over
time. So, uh,
I did assign readings in the documentary
hypothesis is extraordinarily important
that you do need to understand
that it is one hypothesis,
a major and controlling hypothesis out
there, but it's not without criticism.
Moreover,
while it's a very important and worthwhile
project to analyze the components,
sources and examine their specific
concerns and contribution,
and you'll see that I'm a very
great fan of a fan of p, uh,
we must remember that whatever
sources were woven together, um,
they were woven together with great
skill and care by a final redactor or
redactors who wanted them to be read as
a unity and s and surely that must mean
something. It must mean they can
be read as a unity and, and that,
that's a challenge
that's been issued to us.
So the Bible can be read both
analytically and synthetically.
We need to combine an
awareness of origins, right?
Not Gloss over the problems and the,
and the contradictions and say, well,
we can resolve it by coming up with some
strange scenario that makes both things
work.
Be aware that there are problems,
contradictions these derived
from different sources,
but also be sensitive to the artistry
of the final composition. All right,
and what does it mean that both of these
elements have been retained here side
by side? What is, uh, you know, the,
the sum is greater than
what does the phrase,
the whole is greater than
the sum of the parts, right?
So keep that awareness and in the last
20 years or so, um, source criticism,
actually 30 years or so,
source criticism in the conventional
sense of the analysis of,
of documentary sources has been
supplemented by other new and exciting
methodologies in the study of the Bible.
And we'll, we'll see some of those.
I've also included as
optional reading for you.
Sometimes I'm a couple of articles
that have analyzed biblical stories are
written by someone who thinks the
documentary hypothesis just doesn't really
help us out much at all.
And she gives some wonderful coherent
readings of stories that argue this,
this scene here or this contradiction
here isn't a sign of a different source.
It serves this literary purpose,
that literary purpose.
And I sort of put those in subversively
for you to have a look at, uh,
in your own time.
I'm there.
They're brilliantly written and they
give you insight into the various ways in
which we can read the text.
Um,
but many of the alternative methodologies
for studying the text do assume
sources even in some broad sense, if not
all the details of val houses theory.
So it's clear that a great deal
of Biblical scholarship owes,
owes its accomplishments and its
theories to the work that was done by the
source critics of the 19th century.
I want to flip back to text for a moment
before I returned to talk about a whole
sort of contradictory or
a set of methodologies,
methodologies or methodologies
that pool in another direction.
But first I want to get us up to
the Patriarchs and matriarchs were,
we're going to be starting off on
Monday. We just have had a flood. Um,
and then we move into genesis 10 and
genesis 10 contains a geological table of
nations. Uh, in this
table, uh, people's, uh,
various lands are portrayed as having
descended from a common source of common
ancestor Noah through his three sons,
Yaphet and ham and Shim
a Shim Sham nights.
Semites Shiites are said to
descend from Noah's son Shem.
And the biblical text at this point
is understanding humanity as basically
sharing a common route,
United by a common language.
And the story that follows in genesis
11 can be understood then as an EDL
logical tale.
I had a tail that comes to
explain something in this
tail is coming to explain
the diversification of language.
When we look around,
we see that in fact people don't seem to
be that United in our infect divided by
their languages and so on.
So how are we to account for the
diversification of languages,
the spread of different,
um,
ethnic linguistic groups
throughout the lands of the earth?
If we all come from one
common creative moment,
one common ancestor.
So genesis 11 explains that.
And so the story is there for going to
act as a bridge between the first section
of Genesis, which is a, has a
universal scale, universal scope. And,
uh, what happens in Genesis
beginning in chapter 12,
where we're going to focus in on one
ethnic linguistic group and one land.
And this story serves as the bridge,
first of all,
explaining how it is that a United
humanity speaking a common language even
becomes diversified
linguistically and ethnically.
To then focus in on one
group and one land, um,
babble babble,
pronounce Bovell in Hebrew is Babylon.
The Tower in the story of the Tower
of Babel is identified by scholars,
is a very famous tower,
a Ziggurat,
a Ziggurat to Marduk in Babylon.
Um,
the bibles, hostility
to Babylon. After all,
it's going to be the Babylonians who
are going to destroy them in five 86.
But the Bible's hostility to Babylon
and it's imperialism is clear.
This story has a sort of satirical tone.
The word babbled Bovell means gate of the,
but it's, um, the basis for
a wonderful pun in Hebrew,
which also actually happens
to work in English and babble.
I'm nonsensical speaking. All
right. Confusion of language. Uh,
and I think there's obviously
some automotive pick quality
to babble that makes
it have that kind of a meaning both in,
in the English and a
similar word and the Hebrew.
So this,
uh,
this word can also with a little bit
of punning main confusion or confused
language.
Um,
so this mighty tower that was obviously
the pride of Babylon in the ancient
world as represented by the Biblical
story writer as the occasion for the
confusion of human language.
The construction of Mark's Ziggurat
is represented as displeasing to God.
Why are very many possible
interpretations and uh,
our commentaries are full of
them. Um, some interpreters, uh,
view the tower builders as I'm seeking
to elevate themselves to storm heaven by
building a tower with its top in the sky.
Others see the builders as defying
God's direct order. Remember God said,
be fruitful and multiply and fill the
earth to spread out and fill the earth.
But the, these people are
said to come together, right?
They congregate in one place and
instead of spreading out there,
trying to rise high. Um, so, um,
there seems to be a real defiance
of God's design for humanity.
And so God frustrates their plan for a
self monumentalizing and he scatters them
over the face of the earth.
He makes it more difficult for them to
do this again by confusing their tongues.
So once again, there's a very steep
learning curve for this God, right?
He has to keep adjusting things,
um,
depending on what it is
that humans are doing.
So now he's got a confused
their languages. Um,
some interpreters see this
story as representing a
rejection of civilization or
certain aspects of civilization,
monumental architecture, empire building.
These are always things that are
looked upon with suspicion, uh, for,
for most of the biblical
sources and biblical writers,
those sorts of ambitions
are viewed negatively.
They lead to human self-aggrandizement.
They are indicative of an arrogant sort
of self reliance that the profits will
certainly rail against. And in
some sense, a forgetting of God.
So this is a time in
which humans spread out,
lose their unity.
And this is also a time really where
they turn to the worship of other gods.
The first 11 chapters of genesis then
have given us a cosmic universal setting
for the history of Israel.
Those first chapters cover 2,500 years.
If you go through and add up the
chronologies, the rest of Genesis,
genesis 12 through 50,
we'll cover just for generations,
the generations of the
Patriarchs and the matriarchs.
They will be Abraham and Sarah.
They're son Isaac,
his wife Rebecca, their son Jacob
has two wives, Rachel and Leah.
I am leaving out other, um, wives,
but finally their children,
12 sons and one daughter.
So God's focus has shifted dramatically.
The texts focus has shifted
dramatically. Um, why
when you get to the end of genesis 11,
you feel that God has
been rather shut out.
A things aren't going well.
Although God created the Earth as
an intrinsically good paradise,
he created humans in his image.
He provided for them.
Humans to this point have put their
moral freedom pretty much to pour use.
Um, many scholars, Kaufman,
Sarna and others say that one of the
differences then between these myths of
Israel and mythologies of their
neighbors is that in ancient near eastern
mythologies,
you have the struggle of good and evil
cosmic powers in the myths of the Bible.
This is replaced by a struggle between
the will of God and rebellious humans.
So these myths are telling also of a
struggle, but it's on a different plane.
Adam and Eve Cain,
the generation of the flood,
the builders of the Tower of Babel,
God has been continually spurned
or thwarted by these characters.
Um,
so he's withdrawing his focus and his
going to choose to reveal himself to one
small group, as if to say, okay,
you can't reach everybody then me.
See if I can just find one person, one
party, and start from there and build out.
And so in genesis 12,
which begins the second stage of the
Bible's historical narrative, um,
we read that God calls to Abraham to leave
the land of his father's and traveled
to a land which God will
show him beginning a whole
new stage of the biblical
narrative. And we'll, we'll,
we'll sense that there's a very different
feeling when we get to genesis 12.
When you read that material, you'll,
it will feel different to you.
And because of that, we need to
talk a little bit more about, um,
ways to read the biblical text methods of,
of criticism and so on.
Um, in preparation for looking at the
biblical narrative material that deals
specifically with the Israelites,
we need to think of some or learn about
some of the other critical methodologies
that are used in biblical scholarship.
And for a moment we're going to adopt the
role of historian and I'm going to ask
you to think like historians,
whatever that might mean. And now,
and as we move into next week,
and look at genesis 12 through 50,
the source critical method we talked
about today focuses on the hypothetical
period of the compilation of the text
compilation of the four sources into the
Torah. But later, scholars
began to ask, well,
what about the prehistory of those
sources? What were the sources,
sources,
why should that be important?
Remember that the source critics claimed
and concluded that Jep and d were
written from the 10th to
the sixth centuries and the
implication is actually not
just the implication.
The strong assertion of many of them of
them was that despite the fact that they
purport to tell of events
prior to 1000 um, in fact,
they're just not at all
reliable for those periods.
They were written
centuries after the fact.
We really can't know anything
about Israel, Israel's
religion, Israel's history,
religious history before the 10th century.
That was a very dissatisfying conclusion
to many people because the writers of
Jee p and d probably didn't sit down
at typewriters and just invent their
documents out of whole cloth.
It doesn't seem that that's the way
these materials would have been composed.
They didn't invent probably all of
these cultic rules and ritual practices.
All of a sudden it seems likely that
they were drawing on older traditions
themselves, older stories, older
customs, older laws, ritual practices,
and so scholars in the next wave of
biblical scholarship began to ask a
different set of questions.
They became interested in asking what
materials did the compiler or the
compilers of j or e or p draw on in
the composition of those sources.
Did they use more ancient
materials and if so,
can we figure out what they were and do
they contain reliable traditions from
for an earlier stage?
And if so,
then maybe we do have access after
all to information regarding Israelite
history prior to the year 1000 and so
suddenly you see an analytical approach to
the Bible that's going to pull and
the exact opposite direction from the
classical source theory.
And one of the leading scholars to take
up this question was her mom go uncle
whose name is at the
top over there go cool.
Had a great knowledge of
the oral literature of other
cultures, other nations.
And that led him to ask can we perhaps
analyze these for literary source
documents and figure out the pre
literary stages of their development,
what went into their
compilation and composition?
And he found support for this
idea within the Bible itself.
Because at times the Bible seems to
name earlier sources quite explicitly.
We don't have records of
those sources anymore,
but they seem to be named in
the Bible in numbers 2114.
There's a little poetic excerpt that
gives the boundaries between Moab and the
Amorites and it's quoted and it's quoted
and it says it's from the book of the
wars of the Lord.
And it's quoted as if this is a source
of the person who's drawing on and using
in the composition of his texts.
And it's,
it's quoted in a way that makes it sound
as if the source should be familiar to
the reader.
Um,
we also have mention of something called
the book of Your Shar and Joshua that's
also quoted Joshua 10 13 or
sent in second Samuel One,
uh, 18. We have David
lamenting very beautiful,
the meant over the death of
Saul and his beloved Jonathan.
And it seems to actually be an epic song
that recounts acts of Israel's heroes
and he's reciting that now as he
laments over the death of these two.
Um,
and so it seems to be an earlier source
that's been put into the story of David
and his lament. So it seems reasonable in
light of the practices of other people,
other ancient cultures and literatures
as well as some contemporary literatures.
And it seems reasonable in light of
the explicit citation of sources in the
biblical text to suppose that in fact
the four primary documents are themselves
compilations from other source materials
or drawing on written or oral material
from an even earlier period.
So Gunckel began to focus on
these on small little units.
He was interested in small units
within the, the four primary documents.
And he identified genres or forms,
what he called forms,
the German word is it got to him,
got to lung forms,
he would identify these small units
and that gave rise to the name of this
approach,
which is form criticism.
He believed that what he was doing was
identifying older pre literary forms that
had been taken up and incorporated by
the literary sources by j d p And d.
Examples of the kinds of
forms that got to him, um,
that he would identify where
things like a, him a proverb.
We often have biblical texts, quoting
proverbs that seemed to be focusing, um,
laws, rituals, folk stories
of a particular type,
poems, legends, um, songs,
fragments of mythology.
So for example,
he says of Genesis six verses one
through four passage that you've read.
When men began to increase on earth
and daughters were born to them,
the divine beings saw how beautiful the
daughters of men were and took wives
from among them that pleased them.
The Lord said,
my breath shall not abide in man
forever since he to his flesh,
let the days allowed to him be 120 years.
It was then and later too,
that the Nuffield Aleem these giants
of some kind appeared on earth when the
divine beings cohabited with the daughters
of men who bore them offspring. These,
these giants, He's and affiliate and they
were the heroes of old men of renown.
And it's this just stuck
in there in genesis six one
through four, he says this,
this is an older,
a fragment of a mythology or a
legend which has put into place here.
It's explaining the origin of
heroes and great men of renown.
And the old days. He also says that
there are ed illogical stories.
We've talked about those legends that
give the origin of a name or a ritual or
an institution. There are different
types of EDL, illogical stories.
He says there are ethnological legends
that will give you the story accounting
for the origin of a particular
people. So the Moabites, for example,
in the ammonites,
not a flattering story at all.
I'm following the destruction
of Sodom and Gomorrah.
Obviously the Israelites didn't care for
those people very much and gave them a
pretty nasty, uh, origin.
Um, we also have, um,
etymological legends because they're
explaining the name of something.
It's given this particular name because
of an etymological connection with some
event, um, earlier.
So all of these things he argues are
probably older existing traditions that
have been taken up and adapted by the
biblical writer and they may preserve some
historical reminiscence.
More importantly,
more important than the actual events
that they might be reporting is the fact
that behind each of these
is some sort of function.
Each one of these did some
sort of cultural work.
It had some function or setting in life.
And that's what we can discover
when we isolate these forms,
this setting in life.
And that helps us learn something about
ancient Israelite society or culture way
before the 10th century.
That's Google's claim.
So form criticism wasn't content with
just identifying these various types of
material, these various genres.
It asked what was their function,
what was there sits in lave and
what was their situation in life,
their cultural context.
What does it tell us that we have
a large number of liturgical texts?
What does it tell us that we have a large
number of texts that seem to point to
some sort of judicial context?
What does it tell us that we have a
great deal of proverbs or sort of wisdom
material in certain parts of the Bible
that we might date to a certain time?
What does this tell us about society and
what people were doing growing out of
form? Criticism is tradition,
criticism. And, uh, this is, uh,
a type of criticism that focuses on the
transmission of traditional material
through various stages,
oral stages and literary stages until
it reaches its present form in the text.
Now, you can imagine as a story
is told and then it's retold,
it is obviously changed and adapted.
Um,
tradition criticism looks at that.
Looking at ancient near eastern
parallels are very helpful.
You can see how some of those motifs
and themes were changed right in the,
in the process of being transmitted
within Israelite Culture and society. Uh,
and again to serve some sort of
cultural function or purpose.
So the present texts of the
pentitude obviously rests on a very,
very long period of transmission, both
oral, oral recitation and transmission.
Very much like the Greek classics,
Homer's classics, the Odyssey, the Iliad.
They also had a long history of oral
recitation and transmission and were
transformed along the way.
And tradition.
Criticism likes to look at the way
people receive traditional material,
a rework it and creative ways,
and then adapt it to their own
purposes and context and transmit it.
Sometimes that process is
reflected in the Bible itself. Um,
traditions in one part of the Bible
will be picked up in a later part of the
Bible and written rather differently
with a different point of view.
So Deuteronomy for example,
recounts events that we've
also read about an exodus.
And sometimes the
differences are startling.
Sometimes there are completely
new emphases and the story
can come out and to be
a very,
very different story.
A first and second chronicles are a
retelling and a reworking of much of the
material from genesis through
second kings. And it tells that a,
it cleans up a lot of the
embarrassing moments. Um, it
presses its own themes. Um,
and, and retelling those stories early
laws are subject to re-interpretation.
Ezekiel comes along and does some
interesting things with some of the legal
material that we find in Leviticus. This
is all the kind of thing that tradition,
criticism looks at.
Tradition criticism wants to uncover the
changes that occur in the transmission
of traditional material. It's already
happening. We can see it within the Bible.
And the assumption therefore,
is that it's happened before the
material even gets into the Bible.
Perhaps we can figure some of that out.
And it's a process that also aids
in historical reconstruction.
So you can see after classic source
criticism which came along and sort of you
know, leveled people's interest in
anything before the 10th century and said,
all we have are these written accounts
that reflect the biases of the people at
the time who wrote them.
You then have a rise of of of types of
scholarship that say we're not satisfied
with that.
That's not really how literature works.
People don't sit down and vent
things out of whole cloth,
particularly material of this type.
It clearly has a history there.
Clearly drawing on sources and maybe we
can use analytical tools to figure out
something about the period that you
might think would be lost to history.
So these types of criticism
are emphasizing the real
life historical setting of
the materials that are
in the biblical sources,
their relationship to the wider culture.
That's something that earlier source
criticism didn't care too much about.
All of these analytical modes of
studying the Bible. By analytical,
I mean sitting down and
analyzing the features,
the literary features of the text
and drawing conclusions from them.
All of these modes of examining the Bible,
most of them developed by German
scholars can be contrasted with a North
American tradition of
scholarship, which emphasized, um,
the correlation of Biblical
and archeological data.
I've written the name Albright.
William F Albright was a leading scholar
at the American School of Biblical
studies and he was an expert in the fields
of Palestinian archeology and a Siri
ology.
He focused on illustrating the Bible with
the ancient near eastern sources that
at that time where were newly coming
to light archeological findings.
And his argument was,
and it's an argument that's to a
large degree not accepted anymore,
but his argument at the time was
that archaeology supported the basic
historicity of biblical tradition.
And there are some definite
problems, however, with
viewing the Bible as history.
Um, there are certainly
problems with chronology.
It's hard to pin down
dates on a lot of things.
Many of the events were given more
than one date. A lot of the numbers,
the Bible tends to use ideal numbers.
It tends to use fives and multiples of
fives are multiples of five plus seven.
You have 10 generations from Adam to Noah.
You have 10 generations
from Noah to Abraham.
These things begin to raise suspicions.
We have suspicious repetitions of events,
things that happen to two or
more of the Patriarchs twice.
Abraham goes into foreign territory and
tries to pass his wife off as his sister.
Isaac does the same thing.
Are these three versions of one basic
tradition that got assigned to different
patriarchs?
Are we supposed to think of these as
representing three separate historical
incidents? What's the likelihood
of these things happening?
Is that historically reasonable?
So there are lots of reasons to feel
that biblical chronologies of the
patriarchal period are not accurate.
Historical records,
I used that phrase with uh,
some timidity,
but in the 20th century,
scholars of all bright school argued that
many of the traditions and the book of
Genesis contained authentic reflections
of the historical period they claimed to
deal with and they cited a
number of considerations.
So we'll take those up on Monday.
But I would like you,
as you read genesis 12 and forward
and think about that material,
I'd like you to ask yourself,
is this historical writing?
Why? What criteria do I
judge historical writing?
What do I think historical writing is?
What makes some writing historical?
What makes other writing fictional?
Where do we get these genres from?
Why is it so important to us
to figure out what this is?
Think about some of those issues,
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that as we turned to the text in genesis
12.